wait okay so just to summarize what
you've said you agree that basically
they're unreasonable suspicion at the
moment they haven't got enough evidence
to prosecute or convict that was
basically my argument right at the
beginning in terms of international law
let me let me be clear what you keep
saying is I think I feel I believe I've
been saying international law that's a
big difference between what both me and
you doing in terms of why that hasn't
been highlighted well that's why they
got Tina glandian who is actually an
expert in international law and human
rights law and if the Rome if
if the Romanian system does not one does
not basically follow what are the
regulations then I do believe that that
will be an Avenue that will take so
there's a reason why there's a human
rights lawyer that's now been included
into the team so and she's explained
that there is contravention but how you
find contravention is by applying a make
an application so that's but that will
be the steps that they'll be taken so
yeah I've explained to you what the
contravention is and then I've explained
to you that would that in terms of the
lawyer but the difference between what
I'm doing and what you're doing is I've
actually cited law you're just saying I
feel it's all about feelings and
emotions that's basically what your
arguments are
um
in terms of
um the British women incorrect the
British woman said themselves that the
pro CPS told them that because they were
colluding that's why they never took
their allegations forward but then the
women said guess what no no we won't we
were including we were talking about the
um you know about the wine issue but the
women specifically said that the CPS
told them that is the reason why I
wasn't it wasn't taking forward because
of the voice message that they were
sending in terms of
um the four extra women it's actually
for extra women that who have made
claims again none of that is being
presented to the court none of that has
been verified that has been stayed in
the newspaper but again I can't comment
on that because we haven't got enough
information about that we haven't got
enough allegations on that it and
they're not allegations they're
basically again saying that he's been a
bit again when you look at the
allegations they get very very weak they
do not amount to human trafficking and
that's my point all of these allegations
they don't amount to human trafficking
and you and we know that because why
don't they want to include the CCTV you
know why they don't want to include the
CCTV I know know why they don't want to
include the CCTV because the CCTV will
demonstrate that actually these women
had freedom of movement freedom of a
freedom of doing what they want and it
would give a great window into seeing
that and hence why they're not including
it because they know the damage the case
and that's why they're not including it
into the uh prosecution evidence
and sorry in the last bit the psych
report you've not you're not again oh no
so you already conceded that sorry so
the um do you think that the
international law will change
um or do you think that Romanian law
will change after this case
very recently Romanian law changed
because what happened was Romanian law
had it in there where women weren't
among allowed to work as long hours as
men International
a violate international law and very
recently it was changed so yes that's
the best that's the reasons that's the
reason we have ill or international law
so do you think that the law will change
after this take case about this issue
yeah so this issue is that they've just
not applied the law so they they own
this is part of their opinion no no no
no this is my favorite opinion it's your
opinion no no this is not an opinion I'm
saying they already have this in
Romanian law no the problem is you're
saying the judge and all the court cases
are violating their own law right now
that's an opinion that's a feeling that
you have no no it's not a feeling an
opinion
the articles that I have cited are part
of Romanian law so what I'm trying to
say is that has been overlooked by the
judge so he should look into it so maybe
he will look into it the next one but
the point is the judge has overlooked it
and that's incorrect because you wanted
me to cite examples of where
international law has been contravened
sure so that's why that's in your
opinion that's all that is it's not an
opinion the judge is the judge it's the
legal system you feel like it doesn't
adequately addressed the international
lawsuit that's right John obviously
disagrees with you that's your opinion
though I don't know why you why you
think that that's like a fact that you
can State obviously different people you
probably have an opinion that the
Patriot Act or something also violates
International laws but that would be an
opinion so so I I I I know that the
Patriot actors in Internet doesn't
violate International laws and neither
does the Romanian system I'm saying ish
what should happen is in terms of the
Patriot Act in terms of the the same
rules in the United Kingdom terrorism
act in terms of the Romanian system in
the 180 days I'm saying that I had I I
said it right at the beginning that that
my argument based on that isn't based on
law so that is my opinion that that
should be changed because I think that's
unethical that you can detain someone
especially when most of these people who
are being detained are from Minority
communities sure and you say for the
Romanian law you think it's a statement
of fact that the judge is violating
their own laws that whole that whole
process right now everybody look look
that's not how law works this when you
when you if you think that the law works
that a judge basically applies certain
laws in a scenario and doesn't either
consider because that actually happens
just sometimes don't consider certain
laws and that can be an oversight or it
could be that the judge doesn't agree
with it that could have happened as well
so I'm not saying that that the judge
did it on purpose it's possible it was
just an oversight or it could be that
the test legal team didn't even present
it that could be it as well but the pot
and that's why they've got Tina glandian
in the in in the foreign she's not their
lawyer though right isn't she just their
U.S lawyer she's not even the one that's
allowed inside the jail so if they were
serious about getting somebody to
challenge this on like an international
right stage is she bringing an
international Case forward like she I
thought that she was just the U.S
representative they have she's not part
of the Romanian legal team so I think
you just hit onto a very important point
so Tina glandian can't represent they
can't represent them inside the Romanian
call but she can represent them in the
international stage so yeah if this went
further into the international State she
would be able to represent them and
based on that she should be allowed to
see them so again that's another
contravention don't you think that's
unacceptable that a lawyer who we Ascend
there's a possibility that these
articles have been contravened is
they're not allowed to see her clients
to be able to mount and understand their
position and their arguments and their
mouth that defense in the international
call do you think that is an actual
violation of you no I've never heard of
that it's this that if I get arrested
here in London for doing something that
I can necessarily demand a U.S lawyer
that flies over to here and has rights
to access me in prison or anything else
I've never heard that as an
international law before that's no no no
no you have an access to your legal
counseling is an international access to
their Romanian they have access to their
Romanian legal council for the case
within Romania if this case was to be
taken to the international stage they
would need access to the international
lawyer which would be this person and
then at the international stage
how does a case go into an international
stage you basically retain someone they
speak to you you build your case and
then you mount it what are you talking
about that's literally what happens so
basically in your mind what happens is
you you own your attention is only made
when you make the application that's
literally not how law works that's
literally not how the system works what
you're talking about my guess would be
that in the middle of your guesses okay
the fact of the matter is is in the
middle of an investigation for another
case you probably couldn't bring an
international Case at the very same time
I don't know yours is a fact well I'm
I'm saying prove it's a factor I've
explained to you how the law Works
you're saying that if she even retained
for an international Case right now has
she filed an international Case I've
just explained to you so now so
everything you're saying is an opinion
you have no you have no basement even
believe that you will file internet you
have no idea about that I've just
explained to you that there's a reason
why that there's a human rights to the
lawyer involved there's a reason why
she's actually stated human rights laws
within within the public sphere and what
I'm saying is it could be that they
don't file it the pro issue is this
because that actually happens the whole
point is she should be having access to
her and to her clients to be able to
determine if the case is going to be
strong enough because what if they
reveal something to her and then she
thinks that's not a good hour Avenger
what if they don't want to go down the
Avenue and that's why you need to have
access to your lawyers that's right I
don't think I don't think that in every
country I don't think that you can
demand to have an international lawyer
step in when you're in the middle of a
local uh or a local Court proceeding and
every country well not in every country
but I just Googled it says the right
requires the accused to have access to a
lawyer at all stages of criminal
proceedings including the initial period
of police detention questioning and
investigation of lawyer yes they have
that to their Romanian lawyer but what
he's saying is they also have a U.S
lawyer that they feel should be able to
come in and represent them from
International account you should have
access to all your lawyers that's I'm
not sure why we're arguing this like
this if if your argument was this if my
argument was this you should they should
have access to the international law
Athena for the Romanian case you are
right I I and that's that's why I never
made that argument because that's true
and if you want to make the argument
that if they file an international case
they should have access to an
international law then sure that's fine
too but my understanding is Tina has not
been retained to file an international
Case yeah she might talk about
International legal violation or
whatever but of course she's going to
say that she's their lawyer that's her
job she's supposed to say whatever she
can to make them look good but if she
wants to go and actually file an
international case then we would be
having a different conversation the
Romanian authorities were saying you
can't talk to these people uh because
we've got them in our prisons right now
then that probably wouldn't be do you
accept that you're going to retain a
lawyer and that that lawyer can act for
you before you make an application
um sure but I don't know if that lawyer
should have access to you while you're
in foreign how can she make an
application if she doesn't have access
to you what why don't you make a phone
call write a letter she's make she's got
right here from these guys right right
come on man when you when you want to
need to talk yeah so that even a phone
call would be access to your lawyer like
what yes so yeah haven't they
communicated with her
um I don't know about in terms of phone
call but you should be able to have
access to your lawyer so how did they
retain her if they're not able to
communicate with her clearly they have
communicated with her my understanding
is she's not allowed into the prison to
actually see them that was the issue
that she had is she actually I think she
flew to Romania and she went with the
remote and they didn't let her into the
president so so again she should be
allowed access because if you're gonna
now she hasn't filed an international
Case status she hasn't filed that case
then let me explain she should have
access to them because when she goes and
sees them in the in the in the prison
one of the things that may surmises
because for example we don't know if
he's in solitary confinement it could I
never brought it up because we don't
know it could be it may not be we don't
know the prison conditions it could be
bad it could be okay she should be she
when she goes in and see them she'll be
able to observe that and then based on
that if conditions are bad if he's in
solitary environment you can that's
another contravention of international
law you could then mount a more
significant defense another additional
arguments in the international sphere so
it's imperative that you can have access
to your lawyer because that's how you
can make in that deduction is this your
illegal factors
yes it says the HR committee has
consistently held that the ICC PR
article 14 requires that the accused be
granted timely access to council unless
it can be shown that there are
compelling reasons to restrict access
um so like wouldn't like it
because that kind of backs up what he's
saying no well there's the unless
there's compelling reason to restrict
access right
every part of the legal system is going
to have a lot of discretion right even
things you're saying like probable cause
or or even beyond that Beyond A
Reasonable Doubt right so if I if I was
gonna file like if I'm just thinking if
I was going to file an international com
like complaint like don't you have to
meet with your lawyer I don't think
they're not going to file an
international flight that's just what
people like him are saying to run
defense from nobody's filing an
international complaint I'm saying I'm
saying hypothetically if he does yeah if
you wanted to file then if he wanted it
so if you wanted to take this to like
the world stage like don't you think he
should be able to meet with his lawyer
yeah if he if they wanted to
legitimately bring a case in front of
the EU or whatever yeah then I think you
should know that right well you'd say
like he has to meet with them first
right well I don't know if he has to
meet face to face for that you don't
think that would be helpful I I don't
know if I don't know what rights are
necessarily like if I get arrested in
like let's say let's say that I get a
speeding ticket here right let's say
that I'm speeding and then I go to jail
right and I'm in holding or whatever let
me process my stuff yet do I have a
right to call a US lawyer and say I want
him to come here and talk to me face to
face because I'm going to file an
international case against you guys I
don't know if you if that right is
afforded to you always my guess is going
to be is that during this detentionary
period they probably don't have that
right afforded to them because it's
during this detention period And before
after or I guess when they say really
after they would have the right to do
that or if they actually start to face
charges or something if charges are
filed against them and now they're held
while they're awaiting trial they
probably would but for this point in
time they probably don't have the right
to that's that's inaccurate additionally
I mean you are a good debate but the
point is the issue is this if you are
gonna file any kind of a case
irrespective of his domestic or it's
International you need to have access to
your lawyer for a domestic case you have
access to your domestic lawyers when in
international cases access to
International lawyers when you're giving
your prison a ticket fine that's a
domestic issue so you'll be accessed to
domestic lawyers if I was basically
um let's say I was um you know my rights
were taken away from me from an
international perspective let's say I
was Assange or something then I would
need access to my International lawyer
so that's literally how it works you
need to see them face to face well you
you should be able to see them set face
to face I'll explain yeah because for
certain things you would need to see
them face to face yes you do because
you don't you don't need face-to-face
I'm going to explain you I'm going to
explain to you yeah so in a telephone
call everybody knows it could be tapped
there's a lot of issues that you can
have that where you don't want to say on
a telephone call that's why you need
face-to-face access so you can be able
to converse on its own ahead and you can
mount a fair defense that's the tenant
of our of all legal systems that you
know that you should not have a scenario
where you you but you could be
self-incriminated so I'm I'm not
understanding why you're not agreeing
with this because I haven't seen
anything that's showing that this is I
haven't seen anything this could be true
do you agree in a telephone call you it
could be tapped and then that could be
theoretically it could be sure and
that's why face to face important sure
but well you haven't proven that they
even have a desire to take this to any
International Court I've just explained
to you that they retained an
international lawyer I've explained to
you that International where she's in
the United States she does and she also
has she is on the UN Council as well and
she has UNP position has she represented
any case in front of an international
court before well based on her CV it
just I would assume that it has but
haven't looked into okay so we don't
know because our last client was like
Jesse Smollett wasn't it it was yeah
okay so I don't know what internet so
when you say human rights yeah that
could just be local criminal defense in
the United States but the the issue is
this
she's
um she's talked about the human rights
violations right she is a human rights
lawyer international human rights lawyer
because you keep on making it sound like
a domestic and then and then I've cited
certain articles I've been breached
there's possible possible oh this could
be breach like solitary confinement
um poor prison conditions which will
reach EC uh European call of Human
Rights
and So based on that they should have
faced as you agree because face-to-face
is more important based on typing in
these type of things what we've already
explained it should they should have
face-to-face contact if after speaking
to her then she doesn't feel like that's
a viable uh defense or she doesn't feel
as a viable Avenue to go that's fine but
that's the whole reason you retain
lawyers your 10 lawyers they tell you
the strengths and weaknesses of going
down a certain Avenue and then you make
a decision
you mentioned international human rights
layer is there like a special license
you need to do like international law
can you just like pass the bar exam in a
state in the United States and now you
can do like International court cases in
front of the EU or is she actually
licensed as like an international lawyer
she is
yeah check it out I'm curious and then
secondly if we're so paranoid about the
telephone call being tapped couldn't a
face-to-face conversation be tapped as
well
that's possible but then at the same
time it's less likely hence why you have
face to face and there's a there's a
requirement that you basically aren't so
I agree there is a possibility less
likely it is less likely do you agree no
it is less likely I think that if
somebody's going to tap a phone call in
today's day and age I'm pretty sure they
would just tap the room it wouldn't
surprise me if all of those rooms
recorded
do you know if she's is she like an
internationally licensed and to work as
an internet oh you want me to look up
the actual yeah I'm just curious if the
actual Tina um Tina what's her name
glendian grandyan gallan Glenn
[Music]
let's wait with baited breath cool
um Tina glandon is a U.S legal advisor
who's a partner wait hold on so you want
to know like what specific I'm just
curious international law because she
knows she does she does I mean you can
check it later but she knows I'm just
Wikipedia I'm sure it'll say it so she's
a U.S legal advisor who's a partner with
a fur Law Firm
say this garago they're gonna make fun
of me garagos and giragos
okay yeah
people can check that out anyway it's
online as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible